you get called that me live on the
Internet
sure hi I'm Henry Cavill and I'm here at
BuzzFeed to read some first tweets it
goes Henry Cavill I love you with your
glowing skin and your perfect face and
the beautiful curls in your hair
I just want to hug you because you are
the love of my life people not nearly as
thirsty as I thought they might be I've
read worse things in my comments United
tops of smash broz Henry Cavill what can
like stick his tongue down my throat I
guess Thanks thanks for the opportunity
that definitely got thirstier henry
cavill could destroy my body and my life
and all I'd say is so does tomorrow work
for you too
yes Sam tomorrow does work can they do
can I just say it
henry cavill can destroy me like legit
he can Superman this whole that's very
kind of you
I appreciate your vigor but don't hurt
yourself be careful out there I would
let Henry Cavill split me in half I'm
just gonna say it
thanks for saying it what do people get
up to in their free time
henry cavill could leave me on read at
4:30 text back at 8:47 and I'd reply
at 8:46 it's a neat trick I really do
need to get Twitter it's about how it's
really my stuff ok this is the last one
henry cavill definitely exudes big dick
energy and to make it even better I'm
99% sure he's actually big and I'm weak
just thinking about it
thank you why the 1% I ask and
furthermore no comment see you BuzzFeed
thank you very much for your thirsty
tweets very very entertaining and
complimentary and I'm probably getting
Twitter now thanks
[Music]